so I don't see I don't think it's a
problem I think the problem comes from
where women try to strive for equality
yeah so it goes back to the double
standards I will take the double
standards that benefit me yeah and
discard the rest yeah I don't mind being
a breadwinner I don't mind having that
responsibility likewise
step up if you're pushing for equality
then you can't have that say no more
that don't make sense no it's so good if
a woman goes to work and owns money so
I'm very happy with that believe me you
go earn 50 of household income combine
that's 100 Grand a year we are happy
content we can do that from home however
however when you're trying to be a man
don't be to just just don't try to be a
man because when men will always protect
you you will not protect the man regards
in any violent confrontations in life
ain't no female is going to protect the
man but do you think it's a side effect
do you think it's a side effect of women
earning as much as men that they now
think that they're equal
with men look people brainwashing people
we are two different creatures you have
biological Hardware well to male was
different and what industries do women
really out earn men in
what corn modeling
what industries do women out earn men
what what industries do women out earn
men in that don't have to do with health
and beauty yeah exactly sexualize only
the industries that sexualize the
outline I don't think that's the women's
fault I think it's the fact that men
have been in power for so long in such
high positions in these roles they find
it harder to give it to women and that's
a societal issue no women don't want to
know now women women women don't want to
do it women don't want to do those jobs
do you want to welcome them all right so
so an oil rate yeah yeah this is a
high-paying job yeah I personally don't
want to do that do you think women
generally want to do it but there's lots
of high paying jobs that women do want
to do but it's harder for them to get to
like I said do you think women generally
want to work on in do you think women
generally want to work in the industries
that are high paying high hours high
stress and high tension do you think
that's what the type of drugs women
generally want to do I'm literally
training to be a doctor high high money
high stress generally all of that right
but you're not a doctor yet but I'm
sorry I understand you're training to be
a doctor but there's a difference
between training to be a doctor and
being a doctor and a lot of times women
get to a certain age and they just see
it's not worth it anymore like I have a
cousin and his his wife is a doctor and
she quit that [ __ ] because she was like
screw this I want to go be home with my
children and I think women get to a
certain age they just want to be with
their kids I don't think it's Society I
don't think it's a power thing I just
think they say screw this I make enough
money that's true I think this does the
the book affluenza where they dictate
the way they documented it where they
were looking at female lawyers and say
that in terms of the law profession
women are actually better in men but the
women will hit at age around the age 13
and just quit yeah and they will try to
retain these women they just don't want
to do it no more having babies in there
that's what they want I remember there's
a there was a beauty queen in America
this year
um Miss I think she was Miss America or
something like that
she very beautiful
um went to the highest Accolade of a law
profession in an American can give got
to I think she got to 30 was single and
all of a sudden a law degree but the
reason why she stood out is because she
she ended up committing suicide and
I think she had a memoir or something
like that I'm not too sure but it was
supposedly due to the stress of
trying to obtain this uh law degree and
finally get in there and quitting
because her father was a lawyer
stepfather was a lawyer so I'm not
saying it contributes solely to build
the pressure she couldn't deal with the
pressure it contributed I don't know I
don't know if it contributes solely to
her demise but in so so somewhat way she
it was a metrics that she was trying to
reach out to I don't think ultimately
women find that real happiness in these
kind of jobs I think women find
happiness in family kids children
because when they reach a certain age
they don't want to do it no more and and
we pick and we pick jobs that make less
money so like men are 23 more times more
likely to die in the workplace than
women we don't talk about that
inequality but we just want the pretty
positions at the top and say oh we want
to make as much money but we don't want
to do the things to get there like my
dad was a top half a percent earner he
worked 70 to 80 hours a week for 30
years I don't want to do that most women
don't want to do that and how would you
do that and have kids in a family it
just doesn't make sense sorry go ahead
um oh you know you just mentioned that
your
hopefully become a doctor that'd be
great for you honestly and when you
become a doctor the job consists of a
high intensity high pressure a lot of
hours
70 80 hours a week right yeah yeah I'm
on placement at the moment okay but you
will never die at work actually your
doctors have one of the highest suicide
rates yeah you can you can kill yourself
if you want but yeah
we're not we're not like you're building
suicide on here you you will not die
because you're a doctor you're patient
might because of your malpractice but on
oil rig you will die if you're not
careful
do you understand your mistake patient
dies my mistake in the Ulrich I die
people randomly die every day
that's that's a massive difference
between men's jobs and females jobs we
tend to lie we love putting our lives on
the line we love doing some dumb Mad
Mental ninja stuff and we will do it and
we love it we love we love getting
battered we love getting shorter we love
it that's why men go to the Army yeah I
get it
Call of Duty
most most medics in the Army are females
they don't have weapons
they don't want a weapon they're not
allowed to have weapons and general
Medics but they don't die Medics don't
die soldiers die they're most men
honestly I'm just letting you know that
it's like most females jobs females
don't tend to die at work they just
don't die but if they're choosing to die
that's their own choice at work if they
want to do a risky job that's their
choice I understand I don't know what
the point is
yeah the whole point is that men build
the world we could not function without
man men allow us to have the jobs that
we have if men didn't do the jobs that
they do we couldn't even work at all men
build the world but can barely run it
have you seen most the countries are run
by men
did you know did you know that women are
more likely to wage war than men
if they're in power they are more likely
to wage war I'm um like that statistic
you could you could Google it if you
Google it but has but have women because
yeah evidently they don't have wages yes
more men are in power so so so okay okay
yeah so more men are in power and have
been in power throughout all of history
and a lot of times we'll look at that
and say oh it's because they're a
pressing woman I'm sorry people get shot
when they're in power people were
assassinated like a lot of people didn't
want to be in that position because it
came with a lot of responsibility and
you had a Target on your back and when
women were in that position they were
more likely to rage War they raged War
at a higher rate
do you know why men make better at
building societies
um because you're saying that you know
female lead societies because their
fathers right and they understand what
it is to protect Society so when you go
into societies you will find the sewered
people that are in the sewers the
plumbers the mechanics the people that
run the infrastructure of the world are
men a lot of them are fathers because
they're doing this because they
understand that they're building a
legacy not only are they building a
legacy they're building a nation for
their child at least or maybe that or
maybe their um their wife or their woman
so when you say things like
women you know are better at running
societies and stuff it's just like well
it's the men that run and build the
infrastructure of societies they always
have done women don't want to do it
maybe the building the infrastructure
but
who runs the countries who runs who who
was running our country Boris Johnson
look at the state of our country we're
in a living crisis who was running
America Donald Trump look at the state
of America
yeah
even with Biden like it's it's still not
where the Western World should be do you
get what I'm saying
let me let me just cut you like we have
the highest standard of living in all of
human history ever we're in 11 crisis
okay I understand I understand that I
understand that but we also have one of
the highest rates of depression
I don't necessarily think that's true I
I just can't imagine during the plague
that they're happier
okay I understand but I'm saying like
comparatively you're making a statement
and I'm saying I I it could be true but
if you ask people during the plague are
you happy right now I just can't imagine
it was are you putting that down to men
the reason why people are so unhappy is
that what you're doing or male leaders
no but I'm saying the state of the
country tree so let's look at our
country right now we're in a living
crisis depression rates are going to go
up suicide rates are going to go up we
saw this in the last recession we had
that was the highest rate of suicides
and you can check the statistics for
this that was like for years and years
and years because we went into a
recession which was led by Imagine
lockdown wasn't was another reason why
depression rates suddenly shot up in
2019 and 2018
um and also suicide rate shut up if you
look at the graph it goes down down
absolutely but yeah and all the policies
that are put in place things that are
put in place the way this country's
going the living crisis was due to men
that were incompetent I'm not saying all
men I'm saying incompetent men but
imagine a lot of women can run things
better if women were more competent why
didn't they do it if women if women were
better at it why aren't they in those
positions there's nothing stopping them
there is a lot of things stopping them
the whole thing is that Society is
stopping them
even everyone here saying women can't
run things that's not people that are
going to vote for women to be president
imagine women okay again again that's
not true because more women vote than
men their women make up the majority
majority of votes there are more women
on the planet than men
are you saying everyone everywhere no
but in the UK and the U.S correct yes
so so this like oh we can't run because
people won't vote for us there's more
women voting so we even we even
recognize ourselves that women don't
make the best leaders yeah I'd like to
know what you think a woman would do
differently if she was in a position as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible